شاحنه وقود لا تزال عالقه هنا في معبر
التائهه قدمتها الاداره الذاتيه كمساعدات
لسكان المنكوبين في محافظه حلب رغم الحاجه
الماسه الى الوقود في مناطق النظام لم
تفضي المفاوضات بين الجانبين الى اي نتيجه
النظام اشترط الحصول على حصه الاسد منها
فرفض الاكراد واصر على ايصالها بانفسهم
الى المنكوبين يتكرروا مشهد وقوف الشاحنات
في التائهه في معبر ام جلود ايضا حيث علقت
30 شاحنه اخرى يقول الاكراد ان لا شرط او
قيد لتسليمها الى المعارضه ويامل السوريون
ان تفتح المعابر امام مساعدات الاداره مثل
ما فتحت امام مساعدات الاهالي التي نجحت
في ادخال 119 شاحنه عبر معبر ام جلود وعون
الدادات المعابر الداخليه تشهد فصلا جديدا
من معارك المتخاصمين وتغلق امام السوريين
المنكوبين في المناطق المتضرره فرص الحصول
على الدعم من سوريين اخرين يحملون نفس
الهويه من معبر التائهه في مدينه منبج
شمال شرق سوريا جمعه كاش لقناتي العربيه
والحدث